Así es fue en el Estado de Campeche
donde tuvo lugar este encuentro
bilateral entre el presidente de Cuba
Miguel Díaz canel y el presidente
mexicano Andrés Manuel López Obrador
fundamentalmente para abordar los
resultados que ha dado Este programa de
apoyo de médicos cubanos en México se
informó que de septiembre a la fecha se
ha cumplido la meta de que 610 médicos
cubanos presten sus servicios
especialistas en 29 áreas de la salud y
que elaboran en 12 estados del país
desde en hospitales grandes hasta
pequeñas clínicas de zonas apartadas de
la montaña de Guerrero o del Desierto de
Baja California Sur por poner un ejemplo
también estuvieron presentes las
autoridades de salud de ambos países por
parte de México el secretario Jorge
Alcocer y por parte de Cuba el ministro
José Ángel portal quienes refirieron que
se han otorgado más de apoyo atención
médica a más de 167 mil pacientes y se
han practicado
más de 7.300 intervenciones quirúrgicas
el presidente López Obrador confió en
que se continuará con este apoyo dijo
que la meta Es que para Julio de este
2023 se tenga completa la plantilla
laboral en las clínicas de hospitales
por lo que pues invitó a que vengan más
médicos cubanos en próximas fechas y se
tiene ya de hecho un convenio para el
arribo de 100 especialistas